[Musique]
m
c'est tout le monde s'excuse y est on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle
vidéo sur call of duty
je pense que j'en ai un peu marre que je
dise à chaque fois adressé ce cousine on
a vu vous devez savoir tish évidemment
mais bon c'est pas donc je fais cette
vidéo tout simplement pour vous bat
montrer à peu près sur pc en tout cas je
vous préviens tout de suite c'est
valable uniquement pour pc parce que je
ne joue pas aux consoles donc je vais
donc je dis donc que je voulais vraiment
vous montrer qu est-ce que deviens tu as
love duty sur pc vous avez très de vous
rendre compte que ben on ne peut pas
faire une partie tranquillement au
sniper pour s'amuser un peu s'entraîner
sans que y ait des gens pour faire tout
foire ya donc un jeu flash quelqu'un à
up à étampes et l'avait peur je lui
bref vous avez vraiment vous apercevoir
donc là là c'était ma première partie en
rentrant découvre la bombe était de
bonne humeur j'ai fini la journée j'en
ai plutôt plutôt tranquille puis bah
voilà première partie je pensais que ça
va être sympa pour le moment il n'y
avait aucun signe de deux nouveaux de
deux spécimens du genre mais mais
malheureusement vous allez très vite
rendre compte que ça va très vite
commencé à partir d'un peu importe le
style a comme ça en plus vous pouvez
vous apercevoir
comment joue à snapper donc née cusco
qu'en principe il passe sauf quelques
fois il passe notamment aussi à cause du
lac je sais pas circuit je sais pas si
cons ceux ci ou là je ne sais pas si sûr
qu'on se faisait ce problème non comme
on est sur pc les gens sont souvent sur
msn ou téléchargent sur forte charge
tout court et puis bah du coup ça leur
bouffe de la connexion et quand c'est
l'autre qui fait sa ba sais c'est pas
cool
du coup on est des connexions et puis on
peut on peut pas ne t'aime pas trop jeu
sniper quoi parce que ça là quand on
tire sur le mec qui ne meurt pas enfin
bon hop un joli hard coupe très bas
comme dans la tronche
là je vais voilà voilà alors là le tout
premier youtube que je me prends donc au
début je me disais bon si en a un ça va
mais évidemment vous allez voir que ce
qui se passe c'est que l'art et les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils font quand wade et
youtube ils font haye me tue au lance
grenades
donc pourquoi pas moi je pourquoi moi je
prendrais pas le lance grenade pour lui
pour lui péter la tronche et du coup hop
ça y est tous les gens jouent au lance
grenades
c'est vraiment vraiment énervant c'est
un phénomène vraiment très très répandue
dans ce call of duty
voilà hop encore une fois à tequila où
vous allez voir qu'il va me saouler tout
au long de la partie celui là bon je
vous laisse admirer me prendre des
nocturnes
non je rigole ce une blague c'est s
ébroué comme line estime-t-il
j'espère que vous serez au moins 10 %
des gens qui regardent la vidéo a rigolé
mais bon couteau lancé qui foire c'est
triste j'essaie à celui-là je ne l'avais
pas vu
j'ai maintenant les rangs parce qu'ils
soient là là j'aurais dû tenter un
travers mais je ne vais pas tenter
généralement pas tenter des trucs de
dingue la partie pour le moment j'ai
fait 4 kg et je suis mort trois fois là
ce qui se passe c'est que je vais
essayer de les contourner
pour les prendre en bacs mais
malheureusement je crois que ça va fois
rien a aussi il n'y a pas que des lance
grenades qui font chier quand même dans
le jeu il ya aussi les honneurs alors
qu'est ce qu'un honneur alors un runner
c'est simple c'est quelqu'un qui se met
un gun avec un coup tactique qui se met
marathon poids légers commando
sympa le coup et qui court sur toute la
map et qu'essaye de pas de tous nous
tous nous couper en morceaux couteau
c'est horrible
non sérieusement c'est fin c'est
vraiment je suis en bas là vous avez pas
dans la partie en a deux ou trois et
aussi deux trains de tu as là je vous
laisse admirer ce fake c'est lé pigera
pas flash ça monsieur moto flash
enfin au sahara que je le dise puisque
si vous avez vu et vous êtes m'a pas
qu'on vous aurez compris enfin bref je
les freaks coop encore celui-là je vais
la regarder
hop là un individu connu je te 4t jeu
repart tranquillement à ça aussi est-ce
que vous aussi vous tentez d fois de
lancer votre couteau en l'air comme ça
on rentre d'hommes à travers la marque
parce que mon rêve c'est d'un jour y
arriver faire comme au les grands
joueurs au non en fait c'est juste
qu'ils font ça à chaque début de partie
qu'au bout d'un moment ça rentre de
d'une fois sur sur 100 soit entre faut
bien mais franchement je ne cache pas
que j'aimerais bien réussir un jour
franchement vous faire un 4 kills avec
une balle de snipe saouchi franchement
ça m'impressionnait donc tout à l'heure
à cet endroit là vous verrez quelqu'un
se téléporter sur moi à la sangoku voilà
alors là j'étais en plein sur le mec je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il n'est pas
moi voilà donc c'est simple un up as
they kill encore une fois donc c'est sûr
je faisais par l'équipe qui avait plutôt
me saouler le runner qui a complètement
foiré qui s'est fait détruire par mon
pote et là regardez regardez
hop là bas alors là j'ai laissé là qu'il
campe à ce qu'il ya vraiment regarder
car mes amis non sans déconner quoi
enfin faut pas déconner un moment faut
arrêter les bêtises franchement là
c'était vraiment abuser ça c'est ça ce
stade là c'est plus comme en hausse et
c'est autre chose c'était importations
enfin bon bref je sais pas si ça vous
énerve bon à mon avis ça doit bien vous
énervez shepard pas je pose action
regardez le campeur surpris et il est
mort j'ai adoré gerra maudissent avons
loupé c'est un peu tout ça je peux vous
promettre que j'ai vraiment dit surprise
quand même faut le faire
pour ce que pour votre question sur avec
quoi je fume pas je vous réponds là bas
j'ai jamais dans la description d'un
mois sur facebook derrière aller mais ma
page facebook c'est vraiment super je
vous remercie déjà 33 personnes qui
aiment ça un mot génial donc je disais
je filme avec fraps si vous voulez des
réglages encore un copain première
partie en plus un j'étais plutôt chaud
si vous voulez un twittos donc pour un
film avec frappe sans lag et vous pouvez
me dire vous ne demandez puis m'a
peut-être que je sois là mon tout
premier tuto un pou pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas je veux aussi remercier au
des gp qui m'a fait mon avatar nouvel
avatar en 3d on se dit solide comme on
dit choi dit bref merci à lee est encore
a foutu une octobre j'en ai marre enfin
du coup bah oui donc je disais donc
merci à eau des gpéens pour l'avatar 3d
c'est génial ce qui me faudrait
maintenant c'est une nouvelle intro aaa
le fait du runner c'est une nouvelle
intro nouvelle intro mais on 3d pas
cette intro a pas entraîné a été plutôt
pas mal on entre on nous avait mis en
jeu
enfin bref j'ai besoin d'un truc en 3d
et voilà encore leur honneur donc je
laisse là quelqu'un parce que j'en ai
j'en avais marre de ce mic regarder quoi
valeur donc voilà donc voilà pourquoi je
fais cette vidéo que je pense que je
l'appellerai pourquoi je n'aime pas mw2
allez prends ta tête
je l'appellerai sûrement pourquoi
pourraient pourquoi pourquoi je n'ai
plus plutôt pourquoi je n'ai plus parce
que j'aimais ce jeu à l'époque où ils
n'avaient pas tous et toutes ces
personnes qui gâchaient le jeu toutes
ces personnes c'est rohner c'est lance
grenade cg dit hakim au 16e p45 ses fins
et pensait qu'on leur bref à écouter
vous remercie je vous fait écouter peu
pourquoi mais écoutez je vous remercie
on a perdu 2 200 points il en fallait
bien perdre avec des renards des
documents face et c'est un bonheur qui
fait le clip final est un peu la stat
catcheur
enfin bon match écoutez on se dit 100
sur une partie comme ça
ça passe ça passait encore la partie de
la grippe a si ça aurait largué là
j'aurais pété un câble enfin bref c'est
tout le monde je vous remercie je mets
la petite enfance un instant tout
l'habituel abonnez vous dès ce matin